[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Presseclub an
diesem Sonntag erst wurde ganz lange
gestritten doch jetzt soll alles ganz
schnell gehen die ampelregierung hat
sich auf das heizungsgesetz geeinigt die
finale Fassung des sogenannten
gebäudeenergiegesetzes der offizielle
Name wurde am Freitag dem Bundestag
zugestellt und soll tatsächlich noch in
der kommenden Woche idealerweise auch
vom Bundesrat verabschiedet werden die
Opposition kritisiert diesen engen
Zeitplan sie sagt in dieser kurzen Zeit
ist es nicht möglich sich über die
ganzen Details dieses komplizierten
Gesetzes zu beugen doch das ist nicht
die einzige Kontroverse die noch droht
vor den Sommerferien soll auch noch der
Haushalt 2024 verabschiedet werden es
gibt also auch wieder Streit ums Geld
unser Thema im Presseclub heute Showdown
um Haushalt und heizungsgesetz bekommt
die Koalition die Kurve und das sind
meine Gäste auf die ich mich sehr freue
Anja Meyer sie ist Chef Reporterin beim
Fokus
Stefan Locke er ist politischer
Korrespondent in Dresden für die
Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung Stefan
Andreas Kasdorf er ist publizistischer
Herausgeber des Tagesspiegel und Stefan
Götz Richter er ist Herausgeber des
Online-Magazins the globalist seien Sie
alle herzlich willkommen und es ist
natürlich reiner Zufall dass drei Gäste
heute Stefan in ihrem Vornamen haben wie
immer können Sie sich auch an der
Diskussion beteiligen in den sozialen
Medien wo unsere Sendung gestreamt wird
ich freue mich auf Ihre Meinungen zum
Thema ja Herr Richter es sieht danach
aus dass dieses heizungsgesetz jetzt
kommende Woche noch verabschiedet werden
könnte ist das ein Erfolg für die
ampelregierung
die Verabschiedung mag ein Erfolg sein
denn irgendwann muss das mal zu Ende
kommen auf der anderen Seite es ist
zugegebenermaßen so dass wir zwei Jahre
lang lange Zeit hatten jetzt mit den
ganzen Krisen über Russland Ukraine
Erdgas und so weiter Corona dass die
Regierung immer in panikmodus regieren
musste nun muss das auch irgendwann mal
zu Ende kommen und wenn ich mir das
heizungsgesetz angucke dann geht es da
in unserem föderalen Staat und meine
hochkomplexe Materie und da ist die alte
Tradition der Bundesrepublik dass man
das mit ein bisschen bedacht und nicht
mit der Pistole am Kopf sozusagen ihr
kriegt am Freitag Montag müsste anfangen
das abzustimmen das erinnert mich an
Parlamente wie in Amerika wo das der
Fall ist in Deutschland ging das
eigentlich immer so dass man komplexe
Sachen denken sollte und gerade hier wo
es darum geht es für zwei drei
Jahrzehnte nicht nur heizungsregeln
sondern das Leben der Haushalte die
Finanzen der privaten Haushalte und
Häuser festzulegen glaube ich da wäre es
sinnvoll mit ein bisschen mehr Bedacht
vorzugehen und jetzt nicht alles auf
Teufel komm raus für Freitag fertig zu
machen ein bisschen Geduld das wünscht
sich auch CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz der
hat dieses Verfahren jetzt in der Kürze
auch schon kritisiert hören wir kurz mal
rein das ist ein völlig inakzeptabler
respektloser Umgang mit dem Deutschen
Bundestag auch mit den Sachverständigen
die jetzt in den nächsten Tagen noch
einmal angehört werden sollen das ist
ohne Vorbild wie die Bundesregierung
hier mit dem Deutschen Bundestag umgeht
und auch mit den Menschen die von einem
solchen Gesetz ja sehr stark betroffen
wären ja das ist harte Kritik von
Friedrich Merz dem Oppositionsführer
Herr Kasdorf hat er recht nö nö also
erstmal diskutieren wir ich bin so ein
bisschen weil Stefan jetzt Richter aber
wir diskutieren dass er nun schon länger
und wer im Parlament sachverständlich
sein will der die wird schon wissen und
was es geht dass das erste dann sind ein
paar Veränderungen vorgenommen worden
die ja auch gewünscht waren die auch
schon diskutiert worden sind und es ist
im Deutschen Bundestag schon auch
abzuverlangen dass er in einer Woche
wenn es denn will tatsächlich dieses
Gesetz durchbekommt also es ist nicht zu
viel verlangt von den Abgeordneten dann
muss halt mal länger dauern dann wird es
länger dann wird es streitig sein oder
am Ende der Woche kommen wir zum
Ergebnis richtig es muss zum Ergebnis
kommen aber es ist nicht so als ob
irgendeiner überrascht würde von dem was
da jetzt ist es ging wie gesagt um
Details und die Details waren klar die
waren strittig diesen benannt worden von
der einen und der anderen Seite auch von
der Union im übrigen und soll immer
keine so tun und Union als ob er nicht
genau Bescheid wüsste denn die haben
übrigens auch mal umweltministerinnen
gestellt und wissen eigentlich schon
auch um was es geht nämlich jetzt mal
wirklich ernst zu machen wenn wir die
Situation als ernst empfinden jetzt gibt
es ein CDU-Abgeordneten Thomas Heilmann
er hat einen Eilantrag beim
Verfassungsgericht eingereicht weil er
sagt wir hatten wir haben nicht genug
Zeit als Parlament uns mit dem Vorgang
zu befassen möglicherweise scheitert das
Gesetz jetzt noch vor der
parlamentarischen Sommerpause Herr Locke
wie blicken sie auf diesen ganzen
Vorgang jetzt
in den auf den letzten Metern noch die
Kurve kriegen ja also ich verstehe das
aus Sicht der Ampelkoalition völlig
verständlich dass man diese dieses
leidige Thema jetzt mal vom Tisch haben
will
als Bürger Sicht finde ich würde man
jetzt ja nur eine Verlängerung oder
würde eine Verlängerung ja nur Sinn
haben wenn man am Ende grundsätzlich
anderes Gesetz kriegen würde also der
ganze Ansatz des Gesetzes den halte ich
schon für falsch aber es ist nicht
abzusehen dass innerhalb der Ampel da
eine grundlegende Änderung da ist und
dann kann man es auch jetzt
verabschieden das heißt wie blicken sie
auf das Verfahren vor dem
Verfassungsgericht meinen sie dass das
noch gestoppt werden könnte allein durch
die Richter jetzt in Karlsruhe da bin
ich kein Jurist das weiß ich nicht
beantworten Frau Meier ihr Blick auf das
Thema und vor allem die Frage warum hat
es denn die Ampel jetzt so eigentlich
also könnte man das mit den ganzen
Auswirkungen dieses Gesetz hat mich auch
noch nach den Sommerferien verabschieden
naja die Ampel hat ja jetzt geschafft
Monate lang die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
zu nerven bis zu stressen und zeitweise
phasenweise auch ein bisschen zu
langweilen mit diesem Thema es ist
einfach wahnsinnig komplex und ich
stimme auch kein Christoph zu also dafür
haben wir ein arbeitsparlament das
müssen die jetzt irgendwie auch mal
hinkriegen und es gibt natürlich auch
fachpolitikerinnen und Politiker die das
erläutern können und vielleicht auch
noch mal in Bezug auf Herrn märz die
Äußerungen sind ja sehr scharf im Ton
finde ich und da kann ich nur sagen ja
ja klar ist bald sind bald
Landtagswahlen also es ist auch ein
Interesse sozusagen die
ampelparteien sozusagen über die
Sommerpause hinaus weiter in so einem
Schwebe und streitzustand zu halten was
schöneres kann ihm eigentlich nicht
passieren gerade
traut sich denn hier jemand am Tisch
eine Beurteilung dieses Gesetzes also in
seinen Details zu das liegt ja jetzt
seit Freitag vor ist es verbessert
worden durch die durch die vielen
Diskussionen wer möchte dazu sagen na ja
also grundsätzlich finde es typischer
Kompromiss dann am Ende ja also wir
haben jetzt kriegen jetzt ab 2024 nur
noch in Neubauten diese Forderung für
diese für diese für diesen Einbau von
diesem
klimafreundlichen Heizungen am Ende aber
es wird dann der Kumpel der der der
ganze Streit wird wieder mit Geld
zugedeckt es kommt 75 prozentige
Förderung dazu das ist so 70 also das
muss man schon da muss man auch relativ
wenig Einkommen haben also das ist so im
Grunde die Fortsetzung ja auch der der
Politik der Ära Merkel wo alle Konflikte
mit Geld zugedeckt worden am Ende lieber
Bruder Stefan ich will nur ganz kurz
sagen das war alles absehbar das war
alles gewollt und absehbar ein Gesetz
darf nicht sozial so ausgehen dass
diejenigen die die Umsteuerung mitmachen
sollen darunter leiden das war auch die
Änderung jetzt waren durchaus absehbar
ist es nicht so als ob das jetzt alles
völlig neu wäre und das man jetzt
Nachschärfen muss also wie war das mit
dem stromgesetz ähm kein Gesetz kommt
also kein Gesetzentwurf also kein Gesetz
kommt zu unsparlament ist nachher wieder
rauskommt ja es ist immer ein Kompromiss
natürlich ist doch gut die Leute haben
jetzt die Gelegenheit und das war ja
auch Bürgerprotest sich darauf
einzustellen dass und das ist mir
besonders wichtig wirklich umgesteuert
wird wir können doch nicht so tun als ob
es diesen Klimawandel nicht gäbe wir
können nicht so tun als ob wir immer so
weitermachen können und ob nicht jeder
von uns etwas dazu tun muss ein Satz
noch wir sind der Staat wir alle sind
der Staat sich irgendein fernes gebildet
wohin wir was delegieren können sagen
mach mal nee so einfach ist es nicht und
jetzt sind wir dann und jetzt kann man
sich aber in aller Ruhe mit diesem
Gesetz beschäftigen und da gibt es
Übergangsfristen was ist
gegenübergangsfristen zu sagen wunderbar
die Wärme diese die wärmeplanung auch
der Kommunen bis 28 das ist alles für
vernünftig eine Check aber eine
Besonderheit an diesem Gesetz an den
ganzen Vorgang war ja nun mal das eine
der ampelparteien also hat im Kabinett
zugestimmt und dann gesagt und übrigens
lassen wir das jetzt noch mal so richtig
durch die Mühle unserer Fraktion laufen
und dann werdet ihr schon sehen das ist
ästhetisch auftritt und hat sich aber
richtig die ganze Zeit hat sich aber in
sachlich bei allen Punkten die Stefan
eben angesprochen hat die reformiert
worden sind wesentlich durchgesetzt wir
müssen
ja das muss man auch wir müssen ein paar
Punkte im Auge behalten erstens mal tun
wir hier am Tisch so als ob Ende der
Woche wenn das im Bundestag durchgeht
das Gesetz geworden ist soweit ich weiß
bedarf dazu noch das Bundesrates der
wird wahrscheinlich nicht die Verfahren
beschleunigen es wird also entweder zu
einer Sondersitzung des Bundesrates
kommt in am Freitag ist die letzte
Sitzung oder es wird Ende September sein
das wäre eine Woche vor der Wahl da
haben übrigens beide Lage also sowohl
die Opposition als auch die Regierung
ein großes Interesse vor den
Landtagswahlen
was mich ein bisschen frappiert hat
unser guter Minister Habeck der sich
sehr engagiert für diese Sachen eins ist
das dafür muss man ihn loben sagt immer
er ist halber denen die entscheidende
Sache die jetzt rausgekommen ist bei der
Reform ist dass wir eine kommunale warme
Planung haben müssen man kann das Pferd
nicht vom Franz Schwanz herauf zweimal
muss erst diese wärmeplanung haben bevor
man den Leuten sagen kann welche Heizung
ob sie in die fernwärmen jetzt
reinkommen und so weiter wo gibt es seit
den 80er Jahren kommunale wärmeplanung
und ein Fernwärmenetz in Ostdeutschland
nein das auch aber
wann gibt's das in dem Herrn habe ich
sehr viel näher stehen dem Dänemark und
auch ein Philosoph der
betriebswirtschaftsminister geworden ist
sollte das eigentlich gewusst haben und
die Frage bleibt ob das so schnell
überhaupt umgesetzt werden kann denn auf
einmal müssen alle Kommunen in
Deutschland diese wärmeplanung machen
und ich kann nur hoffen dass wir so
viele Experten dafür haben das ist
absolut notwendig über 100 Millionen
Halbsatz noch wir müssen in Deutschland
auch mal einigen bewährten Verfahren
festhalten denn die Länder müssen diese
Sachen umsetzen und ich wir kennen das
doch alle wenn das Gesetz schlecht
gemacht ist kommt wieder nur zu
klargewählen und dann kommt eben nicht
zu Klimaschutz
immer noch schlecht gemacht weil das war
ja meine Frage das Risiko besteht und
deshalb muss der Bundesrat sich auch die
Länder müssen diese Sachen umsetzen und
deshalb ist auch entscheidend dass die
Länder darüber gucken damit wir ihn dann
keine Klagen von Leuten haben und so
weiter oder das Risiko ja ja okay
Kommunen über 100.000 bis 26 Kommunen
und 100.000 bis 28 also wir haben jetzt
das Jahr 23 die Kommunen werden noch in
der Lage seine wärmeplanung ist 28 zu
machen mit Verlaub das wird schon gehen
denke ich mal wenn wir das ich sag mal
wenn wir ernst nehmen dass der
Klimawandel bekämpft werden muss und
wenn wir ernst machen wollen darum geht
das nicht anders also insofern kann ich
nicht erkennen dass das von Übel wäre
ich habe nicht argumentiert dass wir die
kommunale wärmeplanung nicht hinkriegen
ich hoffe sehr dass das klappt in den
frühesten da kann man in Deutschland
immer Zweifel dran haben ich habe nur
gesagt dieses Gesetz ist so detailliert
dass jedem Hauseigentümer für jede
Wärmequelle und so weiter hunderttausend
einzeln Vorschriften gemacht werden
bleibt wenn da irgendetwas unsauber ist
gibt's dagegen klagen und deshalb bin
ich dafür dass man das zumindest auf
Bundesland Ebene noch mal gut
durchchecken kann seitens der Verwaltung
damit die über den Sommer vielleicht
nicht in den Urlaub fahren sondern
gucken müssen ob das Gesetz so gut ist
und solide ist ich glaube auch das ist
technisch machbar ist ne das die die
Fachkräfte haben die das dann am Ende
umsetzen können ich glaube die
grundsätzliche Haltung also das die
Leute sagen Klimawandel ist wichtig das
war ja am Anfang so aber durch diese
gesamte Diskussion und durch die Art und
Weise wie dieses Gesetz jetzt in Gang
gesetzt wurde haben viele Leute dabei
verloren ne die jetzt sagen wir finden
es nicht mehr oder sagen wir machen da
nicht mehr mit einfach ne und das ist
der große Schaden der dabei entstanden
ist und das dazu mal bei einer Koalition
die sie am Anfang hingesetzt hat und
gesagt hat wir wollen anders Politik
machen ja wir einigen uns untereinander
wir können dem Gegner auch oder dem dem
bullischen mitwerber auch seine Erfolge
wir reden intern wir machen keine
Nachtsitzung all das findet ja gar nicht
mehr statt sondern es wird gekämpft wie
der Kaiser Streit ist in Ordnung ja um
die bessere Lösung aber gerade beim
Klimawandel finde ich auch bei der bei
der Bekämpfung des Klimawandels muss man
den anderen anders finden ja die Grünen
sind hier ideologisch dabei und das ist
eben sie setzen ihre Ideologie vor den
Pragmatismus und wo die Realität ja wenn
wir sehen dass der ist sie können sofort
zu denken
immer meine wenn ich einen den
Klimawandel bekämpfen will und ich
beschließe eine Energiewende die unter
den normalen Bedingungen wie sie damals
herrschen sinnvoll und richtig ist ja
wenn dann aber eine dieser wesentlichen
Bedingungen nämlich das Gas aus Russland
nicht mehr stattfindet da ist muss ich
das an die Realität anpassen da kann ich
nicht sagen jetzt mache ich erst recht
so weiter und schalte jetzt eben doch
noch die AKWs auch noch ab ja also
burberschaft hat im Oktober 89 gesagt
Gefahren lauern hier auf jene die sich
äh die das Leben nicht beachten was dann
später zu wer zu spät kommt den bestraft
das Leben an und das ist es eben man
muss die Realitäten eben auch im Blick
nehmen ne und dann danach handeln warum
lässt man eben nicht ich will dieses
Gesundheit wieder aufmachen aber nur als
Beispiel
getan dass wir die dass wir die
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen wir
haben nämlich den gesellschaftlichen
Unfrieden der ist enorm im letzten Jahr
gewachsen ne weil die Energiepreise sind
in die Höhe gerockt ja und wir haben die
Leute wusste nicht wo es hingeht und am
Ende kam so ein halbgarer Kompromiss
raus wir lassen die Atomkraftwerke jetzt
bis April 2023 warum bist April weil
vielleicht der Winter dann zu Ende ist
könnte ich mir noch einleuchten aber die
Krise ist ja nicht vorbei ja sehr locker
also die Atomkraftwerke haben wir ja
jetzt abgeschaltet das heißt ihre Kritik
ist vor allem jetzt in zweifacher
Hinsicht die Kommunikation zu dem
Gesetzesvorhaben was viele Menschen
nicht mitgenommen hat und die Grund
gesetzliche Haltung haben sie gerade
ausgeführt dass man eben die die
energievorhaben nicht angepasst hat an
die Situation mit dem Ukraine die hat
noch nach gar nichts dazu gesagt ich
also wenn ich so zuhöre es war doch
allen klar als diese Koalition sich
gebildet hat das wird jetzt weh tun also
wer die Grünen wählt das wird weh tun ja
und das wusste auch die FDP und das
wusste auch die SPD das war jetzt keine
Neuigkeit und tatsächlich finde ich auch
es ist wahnsinnig schlecht kommuniziert
worden es ist vor und zurückgegangen es
ist für die WählerInnen Wähler bis heute
eigentlich nicht zu verstehen was jetzt
alle sitzen nur da und sagen sag
Bescheid wenn es ernst wird ich ich
reagiere dann irgendwie ja also und das
ist natürlich kein guter Politikansatz
das darum gestritten wird super ja so
wir sind in Demokratie und so aber es
war schon irgendwie auf Kosten der der
Partnerin und der Partner eigentlich in
der Ampel und da finde ich und ich tut
mir leid das noch mal sagen zu müssen
ich finde die FDP hat da keine gute
Figur gemacht
das ist das war schon ein bisschen mehr
als nur mal so ein bisschen diskutieren
das war professionell
der eigenen Fraktion muss man jetzt auch
mal sagen also es geht jetzt um das
Thema die FDP und die Grünen die sich ja
an diesem Gesetz
die Grünen waren insofern nicht
ideologisch Anspruch auch hier in
Anspruch ich halte für unterkomplex denn
gäbe ist kein Kompromiss da würde ich
sagen die sind Ideologen Alter entweder
wir machen das so die koalitionsplatz
nein sie sind Willens Schritte zu gehen
und wenn wir immer darauf achteten was
jetzt gerade irgendwo oder was jetzt
gerade durchsetzbar oder was jetzt
gerade verständlich ist wenn wir
keinerlei Zumutung waren das lasse ich
auch in der taz übrig übrigens wenn ihr
dem wenn wir den Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nichts mehr zumuten wollen an
Veränderung ja dann dürfen uns nicht
wundern wenn der klimawand über uns
kommt nun musste das gemacht werden es
musste tatsächlich mit einem Kompromiss
sein der wird jetzt gefunden was ist
daran ideologisch richtig ist dass die
FDP erst zustimmt aber auch das und dann
sich davon absetzt bzw ihre ganzen
Punkte auflistet aber erstens ästhetikes
Auftritt das kann man gut oder schlecht
finden dafür gibt es Wahlen dagegen habe
ich nichts da kann man sagen pass mal
auf so könnte nicht miteinander umgehen
das ist unfreundlich unfair wie auch
immer das zweite ist noch mal dafür gibt
es im Bundestag habe ich auch nichts
dagegen dann geht man mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf übrigens zur Verteidigung
von Herrn Habeck das war am Anfang
Referenten Entwurf und kein
vollständiges Gesetzentwurf das war
irgendwo irgendwo
damit geht man dann mit dem
Gesetzentwurf geht meines Parlament und
dann gehen die fachkundigen hin und
überlegen sich ob das gut ist dass das
das machen eine Checkliste und dann wird
man einen Kompromiss finden der
hoffentlich für das Gemeinwesen für uns
alle gemeinsam gut ist jetzt gucken wir
bitte Wir haben hier gerade einen also
wir wollen ja vom heizungsgesetz und so
ein bisschen auf eine höhere Flughöhe
geben ja weil es geht ja um etwas
Grundsätzliches was sie gerade
beschrieben haben ne einerseits die
Grünen die nach Ansicht von Herrn
Kasdorf durchaus kompromissbereit sind
sonst wäre es jetzt mit dem
heizungsgesetz gar nicht so
weitergegangen andererseits die Rolle
der FDP und wir haben wie ich schon
angekündigt habe ja das nächste Thema
der haushalt24 könnte es wieder auf
einen ähnlichen Konflikt hinauslaufen
die Grünen haben ihre Zustimmung zum
Haushalt 24 abhängig gemacht davon dass
die Kindergrundsicherung finanziert wird
das ist auch ein Vorhaben was im
Koalitionsvertrag drin steht warum ist
dieses Thema für die Grünen jetzt so
wichtig Kindergrundsicherung also jetzt
auch mit dem Blick wer bringt was in der
Ampel durch ne also das ist ja ein
Vorhaben was für die Grünen dazu könnte
man Hendrik wüst zitieren den
wahrscheinlichen Kanzlerkandidaten der
CDU auch wenn Herr märz das nicht gerne
hören
ganz weit nach oben
für die Bundesrepublik bedeutsamen Satz
gesagt
alle Kinder die hier sind sind unsere
Kinder und es ist nun mal so das kann
man in verschiedensten Zeitungen
nachlesen dass nicht genügend der Kinder
aus bildungsfernen und vor allen Dingen
migrantischen und jünger migrantischen
Familien zum Teil aber auch mehrere
Generationen schon hier in die Krippen
kommen Kitas geht noch aber Krippen ist
ein großes Problem weil das sozusagen
die Bürger da untereinander sich was
zuschustern und das ist nicht amtlich
und so weiter und gerade da ist es
entscheidend wir kennen die Zahlen auch
das wieder etwas was Herr Lindemann
gesagt hat von der CDU was die Grünen
eigentlich schätzen müssten der hat
gesagt wir brauchen im Prinzip zwingend
für Kinder ab vier deutsches
Sprachtraining sonst haben die in einer
Gesellschaft wo ist keine Mechaniker
Jobs für links rechts drehen mehr gibt
sondern alles komplex und Mechatroniker
sein werden haben die keine Zukunft mehr
und ich glaube dass da die Grünen auch
bei der Kindersicherung im Prinzip recht
haben wir die FDP sagt umgekehrt zu
Recht wir können nicht immer nur den
Sozialstaat durch weitere Ergänzungen
machen das heißt im Prinzip so kenne ich
das aus Amerika wenn ein
erfordert einen Vorschlag möchte ich
möchte eine Ausgaben wirksame Maßnahme
vorschlagen musste einen Vorschlag zur
Kompensation machen und sagen das muss
gestrichen werden also und angesichts
der Wirtschaftslage ist eigentlich klar
dass das gemacht werden müsste insofern
glaube ich gibt es eine Brücke für FDP
und Grüne über diese schreiten könnten
das zu machen also sie sind
grundsätzlich erstmal bei der
Kindergrundsicherung dabei das ist eine
eine wichtige Maßnahme und es gibt
möglicherweise eine Brücke Frau Meier ja
ich glaube es ist noch keine Zahl dran
wir haben diese Woche in Interview mit
Ricarda lang bei uns im Blatt und die
weich dieser Frage aus also sie sagt sie
wird kommen aber es gibt sozusagen noch
keinen Haken was es kosten wird aber
auch noch mal zur Motivationslage der
Grünen ist die ja Ideologen sind
angeblich ich glaube die sind ja auch
mit diesem
Schlachtruf der sozialökologischen Wände
in diese in diesen Bundestagswahl
Wahlkampf gezogen vor zwei Jahren und
die wollen diesen sozialen Aspekt jetzt
irgendwie auch mal manifestieren und
abrechnen können und man merkt auch also
die die soziale Partei ist eigentlich
die SPD ne so Mindestlohn Grundsicherung
Quatsch Entschuldigung Kindergeld und so
weiter und die Grünen haben da noch
nicht so richtig so in den traut man das
nicht zu es gibt ja diese Erzählung von
dem besser verdienenden und den
Akademikern die ihre Kinder irgendwie
schön aus den allgemeinen Schulen
raushalten und so da ist glaube ich auch
was dran muss man sagen
aber trotzdem braucht diese Partei eine
sozialpolitische Erzählung und das kann
sie über diese Kindergrundsicherung
gleich Herr Castorf hat sich gemeldet
möchte ihn aber die Frage mitgeben also
ich bin ja jetzt beim Haushalt ne und
beim Funktionieren der Regierung da gab
es ja schon Gespräche vorher auch mit
dem Finanzminister also es sind ja
Sachen abgesteckt am Mittwoch soll der
Haushaltsentwurf eingebracht und
verabschiedet werden
was zeigt das denn oder was sagt uns das
über das Funktionieren der Ampel das
jetzt am Thema Kindergrundsicherung
wieder gedroht wird wir stimmen nur zu
wenn und möglicherweise kommt der
Haushalt nicht zustande ja wir dürfen ja
nicht so sensibel sein also das sind
harte Verhandlungen und da geht's ums
Geld da geht es um die zu dass das
Haushaltsbuch der Nationen da gibt man
das Geld aus dass man hat möglichst
wenig von dem was er nicht hat und
deswegen muss man sich auch mal streiten
noch mal wir setzen uns zusammen um uns
auseinanderzusetzen ja das kann ruhig
auch mal härter werden da geht's um
richtig viel und die Kinder
Grundsicherung ja auch da stimme ich
über ein da muss ich sagen da hat die
FDP Punkt also PR Qualitäten hast
postrioritäten es kann nicht alles im
Zentrum sein das kann ich alles wichtig
sein wenn mir das wichtig ist dann ist
was anderes nicht so wichtig die Ukraine
ist wichtig gut die der Klimawandel ist
zu bekämpfen gut die Kinder und
Grundsicherung ist uns wichtig okay und
dann muss man das andere abschichten und
da finde ich auch sind die anderen sage
ich mal tariffähig zu machen die müssen
sagen wo sie sparen wollen oder was ist
das nicht ausgeben wollen das ist
übrigens tatsächlich die Brücke ja also
der der Christian Lindner macht das dass
ich so ein bisschen amerikanisch und ich
finde es ganz gut aufgestellt auch
hatten sozial demokratischen Haushalts
äh Staatssekretär der weiß schon auch
seit Jahrzehnten wie es geht aber schon
unter Schäuble im Amt und der dann
wirklich gespart also da geht schon noch
was und dann wird immer gesagt der
Kanzler mischt sich da ein also
dazugehört der Papi wird da wird er mal
oh oh ja also ja aber wenn das nicht
hält wenn das nicht hätte bei diesen
Fragen ich meine wir leben in einer
ungeheuren Situation keine
Bundesregierung seit
die Bestehen der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat solche Herausforderungen
zu schultern wie diese jetzt hier keine
so sie haben sie haben ja aber der darf
ruhig dabei sitzen die Herausforder
ung haben sie gerade angedeutet vor
allem natürlich der Krieg gegen die
Ukraine eine sehr sehr große
Herausforderung die die ampelregierung
sofort quasi kaum im Amt musste sie
damit klarkommen ich möchte gerne mal
anhand von objektivierten zahlen jetzt
drauf gucken wo stehen denn die
ampelparteien seit der Bundestagswahl
2021 das ist der aktuelle
Deutschlandtrend die SPD ist von 26 auf
jetzt 17 % gefallen die FDP hat sich
faktisch halbiert nur die Grünen kommen
damals wie heute laut aktuell in
Deutschland Trend ungefähr auf 15% und
wir sehen auch die Umfragewerte der AFD
hier mit
19%, die haben sich im Vergleich zu 20
21 fast verdoppelt Herr Locke was sagen
uns diese Zahlen die Grünen sind fast
stabil geblieben im Vergleich zur Wahl
aber die anderen ampelparteien haben
eingebüßt die AFD ist gewachsen
das ist erstmal normaler Vorgang das in
der Mitte in der Legislaturperiode die
Regierungsparteien jetzt nicht die
besten Umfragewerte haben weil sie für
alles für alle unwill die gerade
politisch im Land ist verantwortlich
gemacht werden
wir haben eben diesen neuen Mitspieler
oder vergleichsweise neuen Mitspieler
AFD dann jetzt mit dabei und die sind
eben die Partei die diesen Unmut glaube
ich da jetzt aufsammeln darf welcher
welcher Art auch immer warum haben die
Grünen nicht verloren also Sie haben ja
gerade beschrieben inwiefern die
ideologisch rüberkommen können aber
trotzdem sind sie ja ungefähr genauso
stark wie bei der Bundeswahl ich muss es
mit der Ideologie vielleicht noch mal
noch mal noch mal präzisieren ja auch
man muss doch die Politik die man macht
muss man doch am normalen Leben entlang
machen und kann nicht sagen das ist der
Weg und unabhängig von dem was jetzt
draußen rum uns rum versieht mache ich
jetzt einfach eines weiter und das ist
mir eben im Sinne mit dieser
Energiewende jetzt so passiert ja dass
die dass die wichtig ist und dass die
dass die dass die kommen muss ist doch
vollkommen logisch ja das geben glaube
ich auch die Mehrzahl der Deutschen geht
auch mit ja aber mit solchen mit sol
brachial Vorgehen ja einmal den
eingeschlagenen Weg nicht zu verlassen
wenigstens nicht mal rechts oder links
zu gucken dann kriegt man die doch nicht
verstanden mal bei 24 Prozent
wahrscheinlich ihre bei ihre
kernwählerschaft die ist eben da und die
ist wirklich auch in Umfragen davon
nicht ähm nicht beirren lassen ja aber
obendrauf kommt eben nicht und zur
Kanzlerpartei reicht es offensichtlich
schon lange nicht mehr ich würde gerne
noch mal auf die Bemerkung der Kollegin
mit Ricarda lang zurückkommen die Grünen
sind eine 16% Partei das ist stattlich
in der heutigen Politik aber das heißt
nicht die Mehrheit die österreichischen
Grünen haben damals eine klügere
Entscheidung getroffen die haben gesagt
in der Koalition in Österreich wir
kümmern uns um das Thema Umwelt und da
kriegen wir mehr zusagen unserer
konservativen Partner dafür schalten
weil beim Thema Migration zurück und
lassen die das machen
das halte ich für eine kluge Wahl denn
dass die Grünen sich nicht mit Ruhm
bekleckert haben bei ihren Kernthema
Ökologie das ist glaube ich Konsens am
Tisch das sehr viel mehr dass er Habeck
sich mit sehr viel besseren Männern
umgeben muss die ersten drei kann man
alle auch eine schon weg der zweite in
Trubel der dritte nichts zu sehen wenn
es die Franziska Brantner als fabelhafte
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin nicht
geben würde würde das Ministerium sehr
düster dastehen nationale international
eine tolle Politikerin das Kernproblem
ist nur die SPD wie wir bei der Umfrage
gesehen haben kann den Grünen das sozial
ökologisch Element nicht zugestehen die
SPD hat riesen Probleme die
Industriegewerkschaften krabbeln überall
hin der industriestrompreis wird im
Zweifel nicht kommen es geht um eine
Frage der Identität der SPD zwischen
industriearbeiterpartei und
funktionärste was die meisten in den
Parlamenten und so weiter sind dass
seine Identitätsfrage für die SPD wo sie
aufhören muss den Grünen nachzugeben je
mehr die Grünen sozialpolitische
Förderung stellen sich versuchen damit
zu profilieren wie auch Haus als
Ministerin gestern mehr wird das in der
Koalition zu Krach kommen und wird die
Maxime dass jeder für seine Sache
scheinen muss die sie aufgestellt haben
nicht umsetzen eine Sekunde den Eindruck
habe ich auch dass die SPD Nord im News
ist gerade ja das ja naja nicht so
unrecht also ich finde in der Koalition
muss man sich schon gegenseitig auch was
zugestehen und das eine der Parteien
irgendwie die mit sozialökologie
angetreten ist sagt sie will dann auch
sozial und nicht nur Ökologie finde ich
jetzt nicht verkehrt Lernkompetenz ist
groß genug als für dich aber
entschuldigung aber Entschuldigung die
Asyl und geflüchteten Politik das ist
doch auch eine Kernkompetenz der Gründer
können die doch nicht einfach sagen
sorry da sind wir nicht zuständig das
ist ein
kerngesellschaften
einerseits haben sie gesagt warum
konzentrieren sich die Grünen nicht so
auf Umwelt und Klima Politik wie in
Österreich und lassen migration andere
Leute machen haben sie gerade
widersprochen wir haben auch gerade das
Thema gehabt die SPD ist jetzt auch
nicht so richtig amüsiert ich würde
gerne jetzt ein O-Ton des Kanzlers
Einspielen der war in der Sendung
Maischberger diese Woche zu Gast bei ihm
muss man ja immer zwischen den Zeilen
lesen aber auch bei ihm klingt so ein
bisschen Kritik mit anhören wir mal rein
allerdings ist es so dass wir auch für
mein Verhältnis manchmal sehr lange laut
allen mitteilen wie darüber diskutiert
wird im Ergebnis sind aber mehr
Entscheidungen getroffen worden als in
vielen vielen Jahren davor und zwar alle
die die davon notwendig sind dass unser
Land modernisiert wird dass wir eine
gute wirtschaftliche Zukunft haben und
dass wir CO2 neutral wirtschaften können
und das haben wir in einem Tempo
hingekriegt dass ich mir zwar trotzdem
wünsche dass das manchmal etwas
geschmeidiger gegangen wäre aber das
Tempo haben wir gehalten also das Tempo
wurde gehalten auch wenn es nicht immer
geschmeidig gelaufen ist Herr Kasdorf
sehen Sie das wieder Kanzler in dieser
Regierung spreche aber er hat ja mal in
Deutschland
wir haben ja mal von der Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit gehört tatsache ist dass
sagen wir mal ehrlich das in der kurzen
Zeit in der diese Regierung umarmt das
Ungeheuer vieles verändert worden ist
auch als verändert werden musste aber
immerhin so und jetzt kommt's also die
Sozialdemokraten sind nicht am Jurist ja
ich erinnere mich an eine bundeskarte
wie hieß sie noch 16 Jahre Angela Merkel
die hat sich praktisch auf jedes Thema
das nennen die Engländer shadowing auf
jedes Thema draufgesetzt dass die
Sozialdemokraten gemacht haben machen
wir doch alles und alle haben die Merkel
guck mal an und das ist die Methode
Merkel auch bei Olaf Scholz er hat sich
mal gewünscht wörtlich mehr cool ist in
der Politik der macht das ziemlich cool
entscheidend ist ja kein anderer
Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl aus 16 Jahre
am Abend entscheiden ist was hinten
rauskommt und am Ende werden die Leute
sagen na ja die haben doch schon auch
wenn der Pulverdampf verzogen sich
verzogen hat wenn sie sein Handy haben
ganze Menge haben die da gemacht und den
Grünen bestreiten zu wollen auszugreifen
in die bürgerlichen Milieus in denen sie
wie Frau Meier schon gesagt hat ja schon
längst sind das sind sie ja schon längst
auszugreifen in das was die Menschen
wirklich betrifft in den bürgerlichen
Milieus das kann ich ihnen nicht
verdenken wenn sie wachsen wollen und
welche Partei darf nicht wachsen wollen
jetzt sind sie bei 14 in Umfragen die
können auch ganz schnell wenn sie den
Kontakt zu den bürgerlichen Milieus
halten die auch umweltbewusst leben
wollen auch die geflüchteten aufnehmen
wollen all das und sozialgesinn
möglicherweise auch noch sein möchten
wenn Sie diesen Kontakt halten dann
können die ganz schnell auch wieder bei
24%, wie Angela Merkel 16 Jahre lang
Politik gemacht hat
den CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz gucken ob er
der Kanzlerkandidat ist oder nicht ist
ein anderes Thema machen wir heute hier
nicht hat aber die Migrationspolitik der
Ampel als eine Ursache für die hohen
Werte der AFD genannt eine andere
Flüchtlingspolitik würde dazu führen
dass auch die Umfragewerte der AFD
wieder sinken so sagt das Herz er locker
ist das wirklich so einfach naja also
die Flüchtlinge ist schon oder die
Migrationspolitik ist ein wesentliches
Treiber Thema der AFD seit jeher ne das
ist insofern nichts neues das Problem
von und seiner Partei ist natürlich dass
sie für wesentliche Teile der
Migrationspolitik im mitverantwortlich
gemacht werden nach wie vor und deshalb
sie sehen keine große oder nach wie vor
sind auch deshalb bleiben keine große
große Veränderung da auch da ist wir
müssen da sehr aufpassen ich glaube das
ist dir wichtig jemand hat neulich mal
gesagt das Problem mit unserer
Migrationspolitik ist dass diejenigen
die wir eigentlich hier brauchen zur
Verjüngung zur für Fachkräfte und so
weiter die kommen wir nicht die bekommen
wir nicht weil wir administrativ dafür
nicht gerüstet sind trotz des neuen
einwanderungsfachkräfte gesetzt ist und
diejenigen die eigentlich keinen
Anspruch darauf haben und auch keine
berufliche Zukunft die haben weil sie
kein Deutsch können und so weiter wir
sind eben zum Glück keine koloniale
Nation wie die Spanier die dann
hunderttausende aus Lateinamerika als
Zuwanderer bekommen wir haben massive
Sprachprobleme wir haben keine
Sprachlehrer in den Kitas das führt zu
großen Chaos und ich glaube die
Bevölkerung spürt das immer mehr auch
wenn die Arbeitslosigkeit im Moment noch
nicht steigt aber die Inflation steigt
an die wir sehen auch dass die Industrie
sich absetzt große Konzern
zweifelhaft dass die Situation in den
USA zu Produktion erneuerbarer Energien
der Strompreis und so weiter alles dazu
führt dass sie die Produktion
umverlagern wenn das einmal geschehen
ist kommt die nicht wieder was hängt
dann in der Balance der gesamte
Sozialstaat und es waren die Grünen das
war Annalena baerbock die gut
argumentiert hat im Wahlkampf wir als
Grüne werden sicherstellen dass die
Grundstoffindustrie in Deutschland
bleiben das glaube ich unterschreibt im
Moment kein einziger Vorstandschef
dieser Unternehmen mehr und die sind im
Unterschied zu amerikanischen
unternehmenchefs eher Patrioten aber am
Ende ihren Aktionären verpflichtet und
das führt zu einer Situation in
Deutschland wo rückwirkend auf die
Grünen große Probleme zu kommen niemals
24% sondern sie werden verantwortlich
gemacht werden für diese
Migrationspolitik und es bestätige
Gefahr dass auf der großen Ebene der
Aufrechterhaltung der
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der Bundesrepublik
wir sind nicht mehr unter den Top 20
Ländern in der Welt sie auch noch dafür
verantwortlich gemacht werden zu Unrecht
weil die grüne Umweltminister können
natürlich den Unsinn den die CDU über 20
Jahre gemacht hat ist es nicht tun nicht
wegwischen aber Sie müssen sich total
auf diese Aufgabe konzentrieren das ist
meine Überzeugung wollte als erste
reagieren ja also ich gebe insofern
recht dass wir administrativ eben darauf
nicht vorbereitet sind und das ist nach
wie vor so weil Deutschland sich immer
noch sträubt oder verschiedene
politische Kräfte sie immer noch
sträuben anzuerkennen dass wir in
gewisser Weise in Einwanderungsland sind
und zweitens heutzutage nicht mehr nur
Fachkräfte brauchen sondern eben auch
Arbeitskräfte brauchen und da fehlt es
massiv und jeder Asylbewerber der ihm
kommt oder jetzt im Lande ist dem wird
aber erstmal verboten arbeiten zu gehen
ne und ich finde im Gegenteil müsste vom
ersten Tag ein bisschen eigentlich jetzt
keine Pflicht aber zumindest die
Möglichkeit bestehen dass sie ihrem
Lebensunterhalt selbst verdienen ich
kenne Beispiele nur eins aus einem
kleinen Dorf im Mittelsachsen wo sich
Unmut entzündete weil da 15
minderjährige Flüchtlinge untergebracht
werden sollten da steht gegenüber steht
eine Papierfabrik die haben gesagt wir
brauchen Leute die mal zwei Stunden am
Tag irgendwas mit Arbeiten 100 Meter
darüber laufen müssen das hätten das
selber auch gewollt ne weil die
Befürchtung der Einwohner in dem Land
Dorf war die lang man sich da den ganzen
Tag am Vormittag haben sie
Deutschunterricht mittags müssen Sie ja
wissen wir essen organisieren und die
und die und die Bude mit Putzen haben
wir danken sie nichts zu tun so und dann
wäre das doch eine Win-Win-Situation
gewesen wenn beides mal nein es ist
verboten und an solchen kleinen
Beispielen sieht man eben dass es nicht
funktioniert und man sieht es ähnlich
wie Energiepolitik in der Energiepolitik
dass die Leute zwar glaube ich
grundsätzlich das Problem verstehen und
grundsätzlich auch gut willig sind aber
wenn es in solchen Dingen scheitert sie
dann wenn Sie im politisch verliert ich
möchte noch mal das düstere Bild mit
Blick auf den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland dass sie gerade gezeichnet
haben aufgreifen tatsächlich gibt's
schwache Konjunktur hier bei uns im Land
im Juni sind die Arbeitslosenzahlen
jetzt zum ersten Mal wieder gestiegen
inwiefern ist das auch ein Hemmschuh
oder ein eine minusbilanz der
ampelregierung bis hierhin
tja ich glaube das ist das basiert ich
will das nicht entschuldigen aber das
passiert natürlich auch auf dem auf dem
Ukraine krieg ne also auf den
Herausforderungen die mit diesem Krieg
das ist ja der einzige Punkt wo diese
Ampel sich quasi komplett einig ist also
wo es wirklich
gemeinsame Entscheidung und gemeinsame
Handlung und auch keine großen Debatten
gibt das passiert einfach aber die
Folgen fürs Land und für die Wirtschaft
hier ich glaube bei den
Familienunternehmern glaubt irgendwie
jeder neunte das äh quatschen
entschuldigen dass die Wirtschaft
geschrumpft wird und geben dafür vor
allem den äh grün dafür die
Verantwortung ja das sind natürlich
zahlen die müssen wirklich wirklich
Sorgen machen in diesem Land also weil
wir müssen natürlich auch eine Erzählung
finden dass die Leute auch wollen und
mit dem Fachkräfte einfach losgesetzt
geht's jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen mal
voran in diese Richtung also Gott sei
Dank ja oder auch mit den mit den zu
gewinnen möglich mit den
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten für Rentnerinnen
und Rentner das finde ich auch ein ganz
wichtigen Punkt ja also die Regierung
arbeitet daran eigentlich dass die ganze
Zeit aber es ist bei weitem nicht genug
und wenn es einen guten Vorschlag gibt
dann wird er erstmal quasi zwischen den
Parteien dreimal durch die Mühle bis die
Leute und dieser dieser Raum ja dieser
Diskussionsraum nichts gegen
Diskussionen aber wirklich nur um wenn
man nur um seiner selbst willen
diskutiert der öffnet den Raum für
Populismus da kannst du reingehen und
alles behaupten weil die anderen sind
sich ja nicht ein so jetzt herrsdorf sie
haben lange angekommen
also geflüchteten Politik da fangen wir
mal damit an dass der dass die
Versäumnisse schon unter Angela Merkel
und zwar unter dem Innenminister
begonnen haben und eigentlich müssen
schon längst was ganz anderes machen
müssen und dann hat sich das dann
tradiert und dann kam tatsächlich diese
Welle und das war wirklich sehr
problematisch und bis heute haben sie
geschafft einmal zu sagen Deutschland
so das Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
ist aber und deswegen kann ich so schön
was Sie gesagt haben dass das klang wie
nennt sie Faser die sagt das auch alles
das was Sie gesagt haben also nicht
jedes Sport aber fast alles sagt Nancy
Feser auch da ist jeder da gilt der Satz
jede große Reise beginnt mit einem
ersten Schritt immerhin machen wir jetzt
die ersten Schritte ist nicht so als ob
nichts geschieht es dürfen Menschen zu
uns kommen es dürfen Menschen arbeiten
die geflüchtet werden integriert so gut
wie es geht ja und was die Wirtschaft
angeht kann nur sagen genau die haben
mir das Wort von den Lippen gerissen
gewissermaßen
es ist tatsächlich was haben wir gedacht
es ist ein Krieg mitten in Europa dass
das Auswirkungen haben würde dafür geht
es uns umgekehrt eigentlich noch Gold
Einsatz noch richtig ist ja nicht zu
viel reden aber sagen wir mal so diese
Regierung hat und wenn man etwas
vorwerfen kann dies unter philosophiert
die kann einfach nicht erklären warum
sie das jetzt macht und wie das alles
zusammen gehört
es wäre hilfreich und dass er die
höchste Form der Intellektualität wenn
man sagt etwas auf das ist das Problem
und hier das ist der Kern und den
erkläre ich so schuppenmauer sage
ungewöhnliche Dinge mit gewöhnlichen
Worten dass die Leute verstehen wissen
warum ich das mache und das brauchen wir
nicht zu erwarten also unter
philosophiert oder Streit um das Streits
Willen was erwartet uns denn jetzt nach
der Sommerpause wie geht's mit Blick auf
den Herbst und die Landtagswahlen weiter
herrscht
Erweiterung des Wortes zum Sonntag hier
ein Kanzler der endlich als Szene
Minister agiert er ist der erfahrenste
Minister eines der
erfahrungshöhe
bundeslandchef und so weiter und er
agiert nur als schattenkanzler und dann
ist einfach unverständlich dass er mit
Worten versucht Kommunikation zu
betreiben die völlig aus seinem
Charakter gefahren sind und völlig aus
der wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
Realität Doppelpunkt Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit und wir kriegen ein
Wirtschaftswunder damit hat er sich
einen rhetorischen Hals um den Strick um
den Hals gelegt der nicht sehr
vorteilhaft ist er ist derjenige der bei
den Themen die eben auch du angesprochen
hast hingehen könnte und sagen könnte
Leute wir müssen wir dürfen uns jetzt
nicht nur hinter dem Ukraine Krieg
Verstecken der ist tragisch schwierig
wir tun da einiges auch wenn schon
wieder zeitenwände sehr in Zweifel ist
und so weiter aber wir müssen sehen dass
das was ich vorhin gesagt habe dass die
wirtschaftlichen Grundlagen dieses
Sozialstaates dabei sind auseinander zu
fliegen weil wir nicht mehr die
Industriearbeitsplätze haben das sieht
auch Ministerpräsident weil in
Niedersachsen so ein Sozialdemokrat der
wirklich ein Topmann auch ist das müsste
dieser Kanzler der Bevölkerung gegenüber
auch kommunizieren und dann ist das ein
Ministerin und dem Ministerien gegenüber
sagen und wir müssen wirklich die
Regulierung machen und so weiter und da
kommt von ihm überhaupt nichts man hat
nicht das Gefühl dass der Mann jemals in
Hamburg über in der Bürgermeister
gewesen ist sondern allenfalls aus
Kalifornien kommt aber das Sony Boy
durch die Politik geht und Herrn Harbeck
auflaufen lässt bei diesem
heizungsgesetz was er selber hätte
verhindern können gut dass das fehlt mir
einfach viel von Olaf Scholz von dem was
er hat sich sein Leben lang auf diesen
Job vorbereitet und man merkt davon sehr
wenig das war ein sehr kritischer Blick
auf Olaf Scholz der locke ich würde sie
dazu auch gerne noch hören und Fragen
Friedrich Merz der mögliche
Herausforderer der hat ja jetzt die
Grünen zum Hauptgegner der Bundes also
zum Hauptgegner in der Bundesregierung
erklärt und die AFD zum Feind das ist
die neue Positionierung der CDU wie
hilfreich ist das wenn wir jetzt auf das
gucken was noch nach dem Sommerferien
passiert naja es ist im Umgang mit der
AFD ist es nicht hilfreich sie immer
wieder so zu
Feind zu erklären dazu dämonisieren ist
am besten ist glaube ich eine Strategie
in der man sagt wir springen nicht über
jedes Stückchen was die uns hinhalten ja
wir
ignorieren manchmal viele Sachen gar
nicht mehr die sie überhaupt macht und
grenzen uns aber ansonsten und zwar in
jeder Form in jedem Parlament ob das im
Bundestag im Landtag ist oder auch eine
Kommunalparlament ist von diesen Leuten
ab ja weil sie diese Partei hat mit dem
Land nichts Gutes im Sinn und das muss
man eben auch in ihren Vertretern oder
in ihren Vertretern immer deutlich
machen ja also auch wenn er hoch
angesehene Handwerksmeister im
Kommunalparlament sitzt er doch für eine
Partei an die mit dem Land nichts Gutes
im Sinn hat und dann deswegen finde ich
schwierig wenn jetzt so nach dieser
Landratswahl da in Sonneberg in
Thüringen so gesagt wird also auch vom
Präsident des Landkreistages na ja
gucken wir doch einfach mal ne lassen
wir da mal hin machen und während das
sich doch mal beweisen ja das muss er
ist jetzt gewählt das ist ohnehin klar
ne aber sozusagen das ist das genau die
Strategie auch die AFD will von unten
sozusagen das ist das fällt aufräumen
und Normalität herstellen in die in die
oberen Regionen hin so also insofern
nicht so viel auf die AFD gucken mehr
auch durch Inhalte überzeugen und
durchaus auch streiten das ist ja
sinnvoll und bei drei Partnern in der
Bundesregierung auch Normalität und
nicht immer sind Hysterie ausbrechen vor
allem wenn es um die AFD ich weiß sie
möchten aber wir sind jetzt tatsächlich
Ende der Sendung angekommen nein sie
haben sie haben tatsächlich ja
beschrieben warum der Streit auch
zwischen diesen drei Parteien
konstruktiv sein kann sie haben gesagt
er ist unter
Philosophie unter Philosophie war der
Ausdruck sie haben gesagt Streit und der
streiten wir werden das auf jeden Fall
weiter beobachten und ich bedanke mich
schon bis hierhin für Ihr Interesse an
diesem Presseclub im ersten geht's jetzt
weiter mit dem europamagazin das ist
eine spezialreportage zu wie es hinter
den Türen und rund um einen EU-Gipfel in
Brüssel ausgeht viel Spaß dabei wenn sie
phönixen nachgefragt hören wollen geht
das auf
also nachgefragt auch Phoenix WDR
sozialen Medien vielen Dank für ihn
Interesse und noch einen schönen Sonntag
jetzt wäre die AFD mitgenommen
[Musik]
um Daniel Günther und da sind wir schon
wieder mit Presseclub nachgefragt es
wird munter weiter diskutiert wir haben
hier tatsächlich eine sehr
diskussionsfreudige Runde heute zum
Thema Showdown um Haushalt und
heizungsgesetz bekommt die Koalition die
Kurve und ich freue mich auf unsere
Anruferinnen und Anrufer die sich jetzt
hier direkt beteiligen können und ich
würde als erstes mal nach Stuttgart
gehen zu Stefan eibig guten Tag
wir bleiben bei Stefans guten Morgen ja
genau bei Stefan ich fasse mich ganz
kurz der Punkt ist sie bekommen im
Moment wenn sie Neukunden sind keine
Fachhandwerker fragen sie unterhalten
sich einmal mit einem
heizungsinstallateurbetrieb die haben
ihre Stammkunden zu bedienen sie
brauchen wenn man ein kleines Häuschen
hat selbst wenn man Geld hat und willens
ist sie brauchen für die Umrüstung auf
Wärmepumpe eine gesamte Arbeitswoche sie
kriegen keine Handwerker und das Problem
ist das Politik und Medien dieses Thema
vollkommen ausklammern die Leute werden
in Panik versetzt man bekommt keine
Handwerker vielen Dank auf Wiederhören
danke für dieses Beispiel aus dem
prallen Leben und Frau Meier möchte
darauf reagieren hallo erstmal schönen
guten Tag nach Stuttgart hier ist die
Anja nicht der Stefan ich wollte nur
noch kurz sagen ich habe gerade letzte
Woche mit dem Präsidenten des
Zentralverbandes des deutschen Handwerks
genau darüber gesprochen ne und der die
Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker in diesem
Land sehen das Problem haben aber
eigentlich sozusagen eine ernennt das
Agenda der Hoffnung oder der Positivität
tatsächlich sehen die das Problem
arbeiten an Arbeiten an entschuldigung
das habe ich die richtige Kamera
bekommen und arbeiten an äh Lösung vor
allem Fach also Nachwuchs Problem ja und
ich habe jetzt selbst auch Erfahrung
gemacht mit einer mit einer Wärmepumpe
das geht schon also sie sprachen gerade
von Panik und ich finde das ist ein
bisschen übertrieben es ist eine
Knappheit das ist gar keine Frage und
sehr viele Menschen wollen das und das
werden jetzt noch sehr viel mehr werden
wenn diese Förderung kommen aber ich
glaube dafür haben wir eine breit
aufgestellt Wirtschaft eine
Handwerkerschaft in diesem Land und die
werden das wuppen wenn ich ziemlich
optimistisch wir müssen halt mal
anfangen danke wir gehen weiter nach
Gütersloh zu Evelyn Hildebrand hallo und
ihre Frage bitte
mir ging es darum dass die Firmen jetzt
alle auf Wanderschaft gehen ich denke
das liegt daran dass sie keine günstigen
Rohstoffe mehr kriegen das wiederum
daran liegt dass ich unsere Regierung
unbedingt in der Ukraine einmischen
mussten unsere Waffen produzieren dort
massenhaft CO2
und ich krieg zu hören ich soll meine
Ölheizung abschaffen und CO2 zu sparen
also das sehe ich ehrlich gesagt
überhaupt nicht ein
äh ich habe eher den Eindruck dieses
Theater mit der Heizung hat den Zweck
dass wir einfach nicht mehr mitkriegen
wie weit die CO2 Belastung durch den
Ukraine Krieg gesteigert wird und das
andere Thema die Zuwanderung wir wollen
keine Zuwanderung jedenfalls die große
Menge nicht und wenn unsere Regierung
unsere Politiker das nicht einsehen
wollen dann müssen wir leider diese
schreckliche Partei wählen die ich auf
keinen Fall navigieren haben will aber
wenn sie meinen sie müssen in mir
Millionen Menschen reinlassen dann tut
es mir leid dann wird das so sein also
zwei Fragen einerseits zum Thema
heizungsgesetz das andere zum Thema
Migrationen und Herr Richter hat schon
die Hand gehoben darf ich eine Rückfrage
Stellen ganz unhöflich und zumindest
Fragen sagen dass sie vielleicht nicht
mehr als zehn Jahre vom Rentenalter
entfernt sind
jedenfalls unabhängig von der Antwort
wenn sie als deutsche bei einem
rentenumlageverfahren sicherstellen
wollen dass ihre Rente sicher ist dann
brauchen wir unbedingt produktive
Einwanderer etwa 400.000 im Jahr ich
habe vorhin gesagt wir müssen
sicherstellen dass die richtigen kommen
die die Sprache sprechen zumindest
Englisch die Skills haben und so weiter
sie haben aber gesagt wir sollen keine
einwanderer haben und das kann man in
der Form absolut nicht akzeptieren denn
graben sie sich ihr eigenes graben
können und das ist die Mehrheit bitte
keine die wir brauchen können also die
wir nicht brauchen können also auf das
Haus würde ich mich nicht setzen ich
glaube es gibt in Deutschland wie Anja
gerade gesagt hat auch eine gute
Tradition ich habe lange in Amerika
gelebt da sind viele Leute angekommen
die keine Skills hatten wir beim
nächsten Tag wieder Kollege gesagt hat
arbeiten mussten und dadurch und
arbeiten wollten weil sie nicht nur
Fingernägel fressen wollten und sie viel
gelernt haben in kurzer Zeit und sich
sehr arbeitswillig gemacht haben ich
glaube wir Deutschen haben überall Links
nicht nur in Ostdeutschland ganz große
administrative Probleme auf die Menschen
die arbeitswillig sind zuzugehen und aus
denen das Beste zu ermöglichen und ich
glaube das sollten sie sich sehr stark
überlegen wenn Sie eine halbwegs sichere
Rente haben wollen
danke das war der zweite Aspekt und der
erste war zum heizungsgesetz die
parallele von CO2-Emissionen wegen des
ukrainekriegs ich weiß nicht ob das
jemand schon mal ausgemessen hat aber
das eine hat ja unmittelbar mit dem
anderen nichts zu tun möchte da jemand
auch noch drauf reagieren er Locke ganz
kurz man muss eben Unsinn auch klar
würde ich sagen die neue
verschwörungserzählung das jetzt
ausgerechnet dass du klar ich meine den
Krieg ist natürlich ist nicht klar die
klimafreundlich ne ähm aber ich noch mal
auch das
kommt zu dem was ich am Anfang ganz am
Anfang sagte wir haben ich komme aus der
Lausitz ne da laufen heutzutage die
Kohlekraftwerke auf Volllast ja und es
sind bereits abgeschaltete Blöcke wieder
angeschaltet worden und wir haben heute
im
Jahresverlauf mehr CO2-Produktion als
vor einem Jahr und einem fragt sich der
Normalbürger doch Frage an die Grünen
Stichwort Ideologie ist jetzt der CO2
Ausstoß wichtigste oder sind andere
Linien das wichtigste zum Beispiel
wieder das blöde Thema Abschaltung der
druckkraftwerke ja und dann muss ich ihm
sagen hier muss man erstmal eine klare
Linie ziehen
danke wir gehen weiter zu Margret
Schneider nach Sinzig guten Tag
ich habe eigentlich nur eine Anmerkung
ich finde es unmöglich und unglaublich
dass die Regierung alle öffentlichen
Gebäude rausnimmt anstatt den Bürger zu
zeigen guck her so geht also erstmal
alle öffentlichen Gebäude
klimaneutral machen und den Bürger
zeigen hallo das funktioniert und ihr
könnt euch darauf verlassen dass es
funktioniert nein alles was ihnen der
der Regierung der kostet wird
ausgeklammert und der Bürger soll zahlen
und dann wundern die sich das hier sauer
sind also mich wundert das ehrlich
gesagt nicht ja die Frage ist also was
machen eigentlich die öffentlichen
Gebäude in Sachen Klima Freundlichkeit
und davon gibt es ja verdammt viel die
werden natürlich nicht ausgespart die
Regeln sind völlig bescheuert also muss
ja nicht denken dass da Idioten sehr
Essen natürlich wissen die dass die
Anforderungen auch an sie gestellt ist
und natürlich wenn sie dann irgendeinen
Plan machen der auch gewisse aus ihre
wenn man das so nennen will Gebäude
betrifft und das gilt für
kommunalregierungen wie für die
Bundesregierung nochmal wir haben keine
besseren wir kriegen die die wir selber
wählen und es sind nicht die
schlechtesten wir können dankbar sein in
Deutschland dass wir solche Regierungen
haben also wenn ich in andere Länder
gucken stefan hatte erwähnt werden
andere Ländern gelebt hat der geht hier
fast auf die Knie verdanken weil das
wirklich auch verantwortungslos also
nicht alle aber sagen wir mal so weil es
wirklich verantwortungsbewusste
PolitikerInnen sind die versuchen das
Beste zu machen mal links mal weniger
aber immerhin wir können darüber
diskutieren das auch schon mal was das
können überall auch nicht jedes Land das
ist stimmt danke wir wollen ja möglichst
viele Stimmen von außen hören und wir
sind bei Peter Müller in Heidelberg
hallo und was möchten Sie gerne der
Runde mitgeben
guten Tag Ich wollte fragen ob sie es
auch so sehen dass die Grüne Partei der
beste Wahlhelfer ist für die
ob die Grünen der beste Wahlhelfer für
die AFD sind warum
woher kommt die dann traue ich nicht
mehr mit einer Antwort vor die ich
wünsche gegeben habe beim Thema
Migration ist das sicher so wir müssen
uns bei der AFD in Ergänzung der
Kommentare noch über eines sicher sein
das ist eine völkische rechtsradikale
Partei die mit der Demokratie nichts
gemeinsam hat und wenn ich sehe dass die
18 Prozent hat dann bin ich mir sicher
dass zumindest 12% von denen keine
rechtsradikalen völkischen Wähler sind
das heißt die Wissen über die CDU mit
ihrem ewigen Gemächte und techtel und so
weiter dass sie sowohl sozialkonservativ
und liberale Rechnung die nie aufgehen
wird da muss die CDU sich ehrlich machen
und die CSU
da da profitiert die AFD von wenn das
eine sagen wir mal vernünftige
konservative Partei wäre dann hätte die
ein Potenzial von 30% im Moment so wie
übrigens auch die italienischen
Kommunisten lange Zeit in Italien 30%
hatten weil sie das Sammelbecken aller
unzufriedenen waren und übrigens der
Unterschied vielleicht zu den
Vorstellungen der AFD niemals die Idee
hatten zu regieren sondern vom Moskau
nur als Spielverderber immer betrieben
wurden was ja wiederum auch auf die
Realität der AFD ein bisschen hinweist
also bei migrationsthema ist da glaube
ich schon was dran also
die ganzen Parteien die sogenannten
etablierten Parteien müssen sie an die
eigene Nase fassen man muss wirklich
handhabbare Politik machen also die
Menschen müssen verstehen und was es
geht sie müssen es nachvollziehen können
und es muss zu Ergebnissen führen er
Sonneberg wo der vorhin angesprochen
Sonneberg hatte die SPD vor einigen
Jahren noch 34 Komma ich glaube 2% Punkt
jetzt ist sie bei 8,7 das würde mir als
Sozialamt hat schon auch was sagen das
heißt da hat da hat der Olaf Scholz auch
einen Punkt es muss schneller und klarer
und gerade mehr entschieden werden das
ist übrigens möglicherweise die
Anforderung an diese Bundesregierung wie
an keinem ja an keine andere plus genau
plus dass man verstehen muss ja und und
schwieriger macht sie natürlich die
Tatsache es wird viel mehr mit Spieler
haben politisch ne vorher was eben drei
Parteien und da konnte man schneller
klar sein und heute sind eben sechs und
dann wird es eben schon schwieriger ja
gut aber das ist jetzt mal sagen so in
die politischen System
wir sind hier sehr diskussionsfreudig
möchten aber gerne noch an dieser Stelle
blanker meinen aus Hamburg hören hallo
und guten Tag ja hallo
ja ich hätte eine Frage diese 70 Prozent
ist im Prinzip sehr gut weil dann könnte
man schneller die Sachen durchführen
aber die Frage ist wie wird das
finanziert ich schätze das wird
mindestens 200 Milliarden kosten und
hatte Finanzminister so viel Geld oder
wollen die nur diese 60 Milliarden die
da liegen von Corvette weitergeben und
dann könnte das sein dass ich immer wenn
ich Antrag stelle dann sagen die ja tut
uns leid das Geld ist alle melden sie
sich wieder nächstes Jahr das heißt
gibt's überhaupt genug Geld für die
Förderung von Wärmepumpen zum Beispiel
wer weiß wie viel Geld da in der Kasse
ist das war nicht mir nicht das also bin
überrascht woher sie die Zahl haben kann
sein dass es so viel kostet ich finde
den den grundsätzlichen Ansatz ja schon
falsch wir suchen zu machen habe ich
vorhin schon mal gesagt ja ich würde
eher sagen man müsste ein Anreizsystem
schaffen zum Beispiel auch wo wo sind
die Deutschen sofort dabei wenn sie wenn
sie steuern sparen können ne also warum
ist nicht jeder der sich so eine neue
Heizung einbaut kriegt irgendwie ein
Steuermodell dann am Ende schon hätten
wir ähm du hätten wir die Diskussion
glaube ich vom Tisch 70 % in den Raum zu
stellen also auch gerne dabei sein das
kann schon sein aber trotzdem hat man
immer noch die Leute gegen sich ne ich
möchte nach Harzheim gehen zu Gerd in
Enkel hallo und was möchten Sie die
Runde fragen hallo
und zwar folgendes hat unser
heizprobleme klar erkrankt und
adressiert wenn man sich überlegt dass
60% letztes Jahr in den Neubauten noch
Gas und Öl verbaut worden ist dann läuft
was verkehrt und Leute die neue bauen
die können doch
Bett besser dämmen sie können
Fußbodenheizung einbauen und alles warum
baut man dann noch Öl und gasere ein und
ich werde gern wissen wie viel Leute ab
60 plus haben in den letzten drei Jahren
im Wohnmobil gekauft obwohl sie noch
eine alte Heizung in ihrem Haus haben
vielen Dank das weiß ich nicht ob wir
diese Antwort hier geben können aber die
Frage ist speziell das kann ich auch
nicht verantworten aber ich glaube
dass es schon ich habe mich total
verhaspelt jetzt gerade was war die
erste Frage mit dem Wohnmobil das hat
mich jetzt total wenn wir das Wohnmobil
hat mich jetzt auch ein bisschen
gebracht das ist schon klar wir sind
natürlich in der Gesellschaft die großen
Teilen besitzt stands waren ist
risikoscheue und veränderungsunwillig ne
das kommt natürlich dazu und das macht
das Regieren natürlich noch schwieriger
darauf er will darauf bauen und setzen
hier tatsächlich wenn wir erkannt haben
und was es geht dass ich eine eigene
Nase gefasst dass wir tatsächlich dann
auch zur Veränderung bereit sind und so
schlimm ist es nicht also in Deutschland
sind schon auch manche Veränderungen
möglich geworden das hören wir so in der
ja ich glaube in der Türkei eine letzte
Frage hoffentlich schaffen wir den noch
wir gehen zu Kerstin Weidner nach
Senftenberg hallo ja hallo ich versuche
mich ganz kurz zu fassen und zwar ich
will nicht hier heizungsgesetz und so
eingehen sondern im Gegenteil das ist
für mich das eigentlich das übel dass
sich die ampelregierung zu sehr mit
Nebensächlichkeiten befasst deshalb kann
die AFD so groß werden weil die sozialen
Fragen nicht geklärt werden ich sehe
Kinder Grundsicherung ist eine
Mogelpackung werden die Eltern ganz
schnell erkennen die haben
rentenprobleme gerade hier im Osten die
haben sehr niedrige Renten ein
Rentenniveau eigentlich müssten jeden
Tag direkt mal hier auf der Straße
stehen wir haben mietprobleme ohne Ende
das heizungsgesetz wird noch verstärken
also mir fehlt von allen anderen
Parteien gerade SPD und Linken die
sozialen Probleme zu lösen mit wirklich
guten Lösungen die gibt es
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen und und
und aber das wird überhaupt nicht
getätigt deswegen hat die AFD so viel
Vorlauf und groß aus der lausitze und
aus der Lausitzer Locke möchte gerne an
ja also die AFD hat die denn eine Lösung
also habe ich bisher nicht noch nicht
erkannt eben und deswegen ist er die
Frage warum wird sie denn jetzt gewählt
ne also da da muss man ja aber was ist
denn der wohin soll denn der Protest
führen wenn die Partei keine Lösung hat
muss ich doch mich fragen was denn dann
mein Wähler wurde und ich muss dann auch
mich als Wähler auch mal fragen was für
eine Verantwortung habe ich denn
eigentlich gegenüber dem Gemeinwesen ja
will ich jetzt nur destruktiv wirken
oder will ich auch mal konstruktiv
wirken und da finde ich ist die
warenentscheidung für die AFD immer eine
destruktive Entscheidung richtig
abgestellt dass die soziale Komponente
gerade im Osten weil vielen Menschen
eine Rolle spielt etablierten Parteien
sich die Probleme ja nicht indem ich
eine Partei wähle die erst recht mit der
Sozialpolitik nichts gut ja Frau Weidner
vielen Dank wir sind hier mit am Ende
von Presseclub nachgefragt angekommen
ich bedanke mich für Ihr Interesse wir
werden sicherlich am Thema dran bleiben
wie kriegt die ampelregierung die Kurve
und ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen
Sonntag machen sie es gut bis zum
nächsten Mal
[Musik]
ob man versuchen heute Reihe oder